foreign
[Music]
and Welcome to our Max site sponsored
event titled memory Rich car T-cell
engineering by piggyback transposon
system for solid malignancies my name is
Leslie eschinger and I am the senior
director of Market development at maxite
I will be your moderator for today's
engaging session we encourage you to
participate today by submitting any
questions you may have during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
Send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
I'm excited to introduce our speaker for
today's session Dr shigeki yagu is a
pediatric oncologist and professor at
Shinju University in Japan Dr yagu heads
a basic and translational research
laboratory focused on developing novel
cell and gene therapy approaches for
hematologic and solid malignancies in
particular he is interested in the
clinical application of cellular
immunotherapy including car T and NK
cells thank you for joining us today
shigeki we look forward to this
informative session you may now begin
your presentation
ah thank you very much Ashley for your
kind introduction and thank you very
much for tuning in this webinar it's a
great honor for me to present our team's
project
so today I will talk about the overview
of the transposal-based cortisols
especially piggyback transposing based
car T cells mainly mainly focusing on
its manufacturing process and their
characteristics
uh here's my disclosure
so let me begin with the basic
background of car diesel based
immunotherapies the basically cancer
cells arises every day every time in our
body but the diesel Severance can get
rid of them and how does it happen
this is a schematic how TCL recognize
cancer cells
tumor Associated and zinc is expressed
on MSC class 1 molecule and TC receptor
recognize this ancient and MSC complex
then form another complex with CD3
molecules
and this MSC TCL complex will give an
activation signal to T cells to produce
th1 sidelines
and the ultimately signals will also
activate it after a TCL MSC binding and
will induce full activation of T cells
and this is also a schematic showing how
the quality cells work on the tumor
cells
when quality cells encounter tumor cells
a single chain fragment variables in the
car molecule on T cells recognize the
tumor antigens and this car molecule
aggregate leading to activate CD3 uh
zero chain to to produce th1 cytokine
and kill the tumor cells
car molecule take advantage of BC
receptor or antibody to to recognize
cancer antigens and tissue receptor to
activate T cells
in the upper
this is the very first concept of the
combination of this receptor and TC
receptor from Japanese group
and in the bottom this idea moved to
chimeric single chain from the variables
fused to the intracellular domain of CD3
data chain done by Dr HR Group at that
time this was called tea body
this is a Structure images of core
molecule the Antion binding site of car
molecule can be generated by mimicking
monoclonal antibody for tumor such
antigens
as you can see in the left
the oxygen binding side of the
monoclonal antibody in this case the
epitope lesion of the light chain and
heavy chain is linked by a Linker
protein which is called single chain
fragment variables or sfv
and this sfv lesion was combined with
transmembrane domain and CD3 data chain
this is uh the the first generation car
and this first generation core molecule
did not fully activate T cells because
because the molecule that cosimilarly
domain
so the second or third generation car
was combined with one or more
cosimilarity domains in the car molecule
which can which can fully activate and
induce diesel expansion when the core
molecule recognized the ancients
for the manufacture of karate cells the
peripheral blood mononuclear cells were
collected by by adjusting the blood or
Luke faces
and come transgene was introduced into T
cells then the T cells were expanded X
Vivo and Infused to the autologous
individuals or
currently tests in alternate setting in
some clinical trials
the most successful car diesel therapy
is cd19 specific car T cells for B cell
malignancies
and this car T cells are car T cells
expresses a core molecule that redirect
to cd19 molecule and effectively
effectively eliminates cd19 positive
acute lymph plastic leukemia cells with
a response rate of over 80 percent even
in the relapse cases were not responded
to any current Therapies
and this result of the first clinical
trial of cd-19 protein cells were really
striking and the two more trials have
been done with successful
then cd19 cortisol product was marketed
in 2017 in the U.S by involted farmer
called Camilia
the cost is
cost of this this highly personalized
biological Therapeutics is extremely
expensive but this drug became a game
changer in the treatment of basal tumors
moreover the long-term follow-up data
about the patient treated with chlamydia
has been published and the two-year
overall survival rate was around
50 after Community treatment
so the courtesy Cell Therapy achieved
spectacular success in the treatment of
basal tumors so what is so special about
basal tumors
so B cell tumors have a strong and
unique ancient that is presented in the
presence of ample co-stimulation
however if we try to see what happens in
the case of solid tumors
we have very few antigens that are
strong unique and consistently or stable
expressed
and what's more
the tumors lacks co-stimulations and
harbors and actively hostile tumor
microenvironment
that impaired the function of cortisols
the characteristics of carotene cells
including the ratio of memory or
effective T Cell a greatly influence the
function of cortisols so the Y memory
phenotype is so important for
cortisotherapy
now this is a very good example the
clinical trial data of City 19 Car T
cells for colonic lymphoblastic
glutamine patient
they also that authors divided the
patient into two groups the responders
and no respondents and try to find the
determinant of the clinical responses
and they found that there are no big
differences in the tumor biology or even
disease status between the two groups
but there are significant differences in
the phenotype and the exhaustion
profiles of cortisol in the final
product
as you can see on the top right a car T
Cell established from the responders
exhibited the memory phenotype with less
expression of pd1
and the author concluded that the
phenotype and the presence of earlyities
exhaustion incurity cell product
determine the clinical responses
and as you noticed the most of the
Cartesian products were engineered by
virodin transfer like retro or lentoval
Gene transfer
and lateral or Lane developing transfer
on T cells requires the pre-activation
of T cells however
the conventional pre-activation step by
anti-cd3 cd28 antibodies for
manufacturing of uh wild CD 1930 cells
reduced stem cell membrane-like
phenotype fraction in the final product
as you can see on the left
indeed the excess activation of T cells
could lead to to T cell differentiation
and early diesel exhaustion
the differentiation status of car T
cells is is strongly correlated to the
function of cortisols
and the criticials with stem cell memory
like phenotype as you can see on the
left which has a high proliferation
capacity and longevity in the body
possesses a durable antonym of function
on the other hand
the effects are like cortisols showed
rapid cytotoxicity but in turn this
cytotoxicity is basically transient
and these cells soon became exhausted
and loot their functions
importantly the excess activation of
carotene cells induced differentiation
and the differentiation status of
carotene cells can be greatly affected
by the manufacturing process
so the researchers made a great effort
to produce memory reach less exhausted
cortisol through various modifications
as listed here
and recently there have been a number of
Publications for the Improvement of the
quality of cortisol product
among these modifications I'm I'm going
to highlight these two options in this
talk
so let me begin with the modification of
diesel activation
the signaling pathway of T cells can be
explained in these three signals
on the left the signal one is the tissue
receptor signaling induced by the
antigen simulation and and the following
phosphorylation of the cytoplasmic
lesion of cd30 chain
and this signal one is further enhanced
by signal 2 code simulation and Signal 3
cytokine or chemokine signals
signal one is initiated by the
phosphorylation of item domains in the
CD3 data chain as you can see on the
left
and the intensity of diesel activation
could be modified by blocking the
phosphorylation of the item domain by
Gene modification
in this study the item domains were
genetically modified to be silenced and
reduced them to reduce to the number of
phospholated item domains
the activation of cd30 chain was
modulated by destroying the two item
domain as you can see on the right
to to prevent excessive CD3 data chain
phosphorylation
this is a individual anti-stomer
activity of these modified quality cells
and cd19 criticials having only the
proximal item domain showed reduced
in this case I would say not reduced
optimize T Cell Activation with less
exhaustion status
and these courtesy cells showed a
prolonged tumor control compared to the
original cd19 car D cells
so we have tried to control the TCL
activation by modifying the downstream
pathway of CD TCL signaling
and we're interested in using rasmap
kinase inhibitor trimetanet to control
the TCL activation and enhance the
function of gd2 quality cells against
neuroblastoma because because the
recurrent neuroblastoma cells frequently
acquire rasmap kinase pathway mutations
so the mech inhibitor can be useful for
trading neuroblastoma and the
combination of trimethanate with car T
cells would be great interest to
synergize the function of cortisols
as you can see on the left this is a
real-time cell analyzer data that shows
the perforation of neural Blossom cells
co-cultured with gd2 criticians and also
trimethnic added at a different time
point
the tumor cell group in the analyzer as
you can see as a red line
and these tumor cells were killed by gd2
cortisol soon after gd2 cartesians were
added to the tumor tumor cells
but interestingly when trimethnic was
added to the core culture tremendous
immediately controlled to the function
of gd2 car T cells
gd2 cartesians were strongly activated
by the stimulation confirmed by the
strong phosphorylation of arc-12 protein
as you can see on the right and the
transmission effectively blocked the
induction of phospholated Arc protein
and induction of the teeth exaltion
marker including pd1 team 3 and lab 3.
by contrast
uh the population of courtesy cells
induced by the by the antigen
stimulation was not impaired by
trimethnic this is probably because the
main signaling pathway of T Cell
perforation would be signal 2 and would
not be fully blocked by terminal
so we hypothesized that the control
activation of gd2 cartesians by
trimethnic would would enhance the
individual function of gd2 cortisols
so in this case we inoculated
neuroblastoma cells that did not have
rough map kinase pathway mutation so
these neural Bloodstone cells were
basically resistant to terminal
and we gave vehicle a transmission
and ball
so in this trial we gave just 2 millions
of gd2 cortisol that is a relatively low
number of in this kind of experiment
setting
so the anti-tumor efficacy is modest in
the Cartesian only group
but as you can see on the picture
a cortisol vistromatinib showed better
tumor control and criticials were
long-lived in the tumor bearing mice in
the when treated with transmission
okay so the transient inhibition of
cross signaling has been deeply
investigated to block the excessive
diesel activation and following
exhaustion
in this paper the researchers used the
satinib to modify the diesel activation
and they clearly show that the exertion
of inkart T cells is promoted by
excessive car signaling and the
transient inhibition of cross signaling
by the satinib reverses phenotypic
Hallmarks of exhaustion by Remodeling
transcriptionally and genetically
and the restorative anti-sumal
functionality of carotene cells so the
combination strategy of Quality Sales
with molecular targeting drug would be
an appealing option in the future
okay so let me move on to the next topic
use of transposing for cortisol
Manufacturing
So currently the clinically available
card user product are manufactured by
linty or lateral Gene transfer because
because uh the robust transfection
ability and the long history of the use
of serum gene therapy
however a non-viral method including
transposom or messenger RNA are are also
appealing the strategy for making
cortisols
this summarizes uh the characteristics
of Jesus Gene transfer system
that is used for making criticials
the trans person is less immunogenic
with no need for diesel Activation so
that probably preventing diesel
exhaustion
and affordable manufacturing costs them
vial Quality Sales
the possible drawbacks of
transposom-based Gene transfer into T
cell would be the relatively low
transfection efficient efficiency
the first
the type of cells the the activation
method people electroporation and the
type of transposite is dramatically
influence the efficacy of the
engineering
Gene transfer is usually done by the
Electoral pressure method and it's it's
a essential to optimize the condition of
electric operation
and the post activation of electropriate
T cells cyclines or the medium after
Gene transfer also affected uh the
efficacy of the manufacture and quality
of the final product
so our team has been working on piggy
about transposing based car T cells and
here I'm going to show our strategies to
produce piggyback cortisol
so basically we don't use pre-activation
step we just use resting T cells to
prevent the exhaustion of T cells by
intense stimulation with CD3 antibodies
the most pre-clinical studies use
hyperactive transposes to to increase
the transgene insertion but we chose
original piggyback transposes to to
reduce the excess integration to the
genome
so
to maximize the transfection efficiency
the optimization of of electric
operation is critical and in general the
cells could be damaged by Electric
operation and following strong
activation
and susceptible to to activation
industrial deaths
so we use Ancient presentings fetal
cells instead of the use of CD3
antibodies
and also we use il7 and else 15
supplementation to support the expansion
of electroporated T cells
and all of these steps can influence the
final product not only the manufacturing
efficiency but the characteristics of
carotene cells including the phenotype
function and safety profiles
the pvmc-based feeder cells could
effectively expand cd19 car T cells here
are two piggyback cd19 courtesy cells
test in clinical trial in Japan on the
left and in Australia on the right
there are some methodological
differences between these two groups
like using using original Piggyback
transposes in Japan and hyperactive
transposes in Australia
but both groups used pvmc feeder and the
efficacy of cortisol manufacturing was
excellent
so probably the supportive effect of
pbmc fetal cells could be explained by
b-cell fraction
that expresses cd19 antigen and
co-simulation
therefore the B cell would be a suitable
antonym presenting cells for making cd19
car T cells in other words the further
modification should be needed to apply
pbmc fetal cells to the other car diesel
Manufacturing
so we hypothesize that a genetically
modified antigen presenting cells which
expresses modified antenna and
co-stimulation
might mimic the physiological
immunologic synaptos that provide the
optimal activation to T cells
so to prove this concept
using ephp for specific criticians as a
model we developed autologous pbmc
derived fetal cells which over expresses
the modified engine and recombinant
Diesel activators like co-stimulation
and
using these fetal cells we stimulated
contrastive T cells
so we have tried to establish piggyback
Quality Sales targeting ephp4 which is a
cancer antigens widely expressed in
virus tumors but limited and scarce
expression in the normal tissue
by by using genetically modified pbmc
fetal cells expressing antigen and
cosimulation just to mimic the
supportive effect of B cells for the
cd19 criticials manufacturing
so in this case
we divided pbmc one for cortisol
manufacturing and the other for fetal
cell Manufacturing
then we overexpress truncated pphp4 cd80
and form BB ligand genes on fetal cells
in this case we have optimized the
electro operation protocol of DNS
transposant plasmid into non-activate
resting T cells with a big help of
maxitin
and finally we got an optimized Electro
operation conditions and the following
expansion protocol
we could obtain over 70 percent of
current positive T cells with dominant
cd8 positive and stem cell memory like
phenotype defined as
cd45la ccl7 positive fraction
and notably these T cells have scarce
pd1 expression as you can see
and in the left panel
the virus tumors including rub meal
sarcoma osteosarcoma and triple negative
breast cancer these cells strongly
expressed ephp4
and when these tumor cells were cultural
with eph eph before cortisols the tumor
cells completely eliminated by eph
before cartesians as you can see in the
right
okay
and this is uh the Striking individual
data of ephp focal T cells that control
tumor growth
piggyback eph before protein cells
showed excellent and tumor efficacy in
Vivo and when we check the peripheral
blood of the mice
ephp for criticials was still detected
in the mice at day 42 suggesting their
longevity
to apply our manufacturing process for
clinical use we established a GMP
compliant large-scale manufacturing of
athb4 cortisols
so in this case we collected pbmc by
look phrases and FICO gradient
centrifugation
then introduce the transgene by the GMP
compliant electric operation machine mxi
GTX and the expanded these cells for 14
days in the cell processing center under
the standard operation procedure
here is the representative phenotype
data of the clinical grade ephb property
itself
and criticials are car positivity was 50
to 60 percent as you can see in the left
and these T cells were predominant for
stem cell memory like phenotype with
less expression of pd1 which is
consistent with our level scale
manufacturing as as shown previously
this shows an interferon gamma
production assay under the stimulation
of a specific antigen
when aphb for courtesies were stimulated
with ephp per molecule these cells
greatly produced into ferm gamma which
indicate the strong specific activation
potency of these cortic cells
the moreover this protocol is also
applied to the patient interrupt pbmc
because we could not obtain large amount
of samples from the patient for just a
test manufacturer this is just a
microscale manufacturing data but
we manufactured correct details using
two different electroporation machines
so in this case I showed machine a and
maxite ATX just to compare the efficacy
of these machines for the manufacturer
from the patient derived samples
as you can see on the left the both
machines showed comparable car
positivity but we can see the
significant differences in the
proliferation capacity after the electro
operation
based on these pre-quential data we will
start a
clinical trial
this year to see the safety and efficacy
of the cells for ephp for positive
tumors
so we have in intensively investigated
piggyback cartesians with another Target
including cd19 gd2 aph B4 and flat 3.
and we got consistent results with a
high population of stem cell memory like
phenotype with cd45 all the expression
from just around 30 percent of cd45
positive pvmc materials
so why
are our car T cells enriched by cd45 are
the positive memory like T cells
to answer this
we divided pbmc into cd45 on the
positive and negative cells and we made
PE box cd19 critics from these two
fractions
this is a contrasting expression on
resting T cells 24 hours after the
preparation and as you can see on the
right
cd45 all the positive pvmc showed much
greater transduction efficiency than our
negative pvmc
then we cultured these criticials for 14
days and check the phenotype so later on
I will mention as early plus car and Ole
minus car
as you can see on the top in early Plus
card we can see more significant
expansion and higher core positive T
cells with memory like T cells
CDA dominant population
and lower pd1 expression and lower
expression of cd57 which is a t cells
senescence marker then in arimala score
as you can see in the bottom
then we check the changes of exhaustion
profile of RL plus or minus cd19 criti
cells with oxygen simulation by
transcriptome analysis
and as you can see on the right
or a plus car showed less expression of
canonical exhaustion markers and these
exhaustion profiles even maintained
after after
antigenous simulation as you can see on
the right panel
we also evaluated exhaustion profile of
all the Plus or or a minus car during
multiple tumorary challenges
in this time we call culture the tumor
cells with only plus or minus course at
an effector Target ratio of one to one
for three days then acquire expression
of pd1 as shown in the left
after that we added a tumor cells are
fresh tumor cells for the second round
and third round and repeated the core
culture and function analysis
as you can see in the histogram
the early plus covers less exhausted I
mean the less expression of pd1 even by
sequential antigen simulation
then we performed an individual stress
test that in which
cartesale dosage was lowered to the
functional limit so that these T cells
should be maintained and expanded in
Vivo to achieve the ant tumor efficacy
and as you can see on the right hand
side our plascar groups showed better
tumor control
then
we evaluated the expansion of courtesy
cells in Vivo by by a sequential bomber
aspiration optimize
in the two long-lived miles treated with
our Plus cortisols
particles were expanded even day 50
after treatment
this reflects the characteristics of the
memory lag phenotype and the longevity
in the body
so in conclusion the transposom quality
cells have appealing characteristics as
their simple manufacturing process and
favorable memory phenotype
and the each manufacturing step of
transposing car T cells could influence
the manufacturing efficacy potency and
safety
the further studies are warranted to
maximize the maximize the clinical
benefit of transposom-based quality
cells
so all the data and
idea and data I have shown today was our
team's effort and I would like to thank
all the club leaders including the past
members of a team
thank you very much for your attention
and I'm very happy to have your question
and comment
perfect
thing now start the live q a portion of
the webinar so if you have any questions
you would like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located in the far left side of your
screen and we'll try to answer as many
questions as we have time for so let's
go ahead and get started our first
question is do you treat cd45 ra
positive car T cells with nek inhibitor
to maintain stemness
yes definitely yes we have some
preliminary results that we made karate
sales from cd40 from other positive PMC
and we trade it with the tumor cells
with a making feeder and
as I showed in the slide the map himself
also
um enhance the ants human activity in
Vivo
probably because the Mac invited uh
blocked the over excessive activation of
the curtisels so probably I believe
still and their computers still
um have some beneficial effects on cd40
from other plus quality cells
okay uh next question what is the
mechanism behind the preferential
transduction of piggyback Vector into ra
positive pbmcs and additionally how can
ra positive cartoon apply
uh this is very good questions so
actually we don't have solid data to
prove the primary mechanism by which the
piggyback transposes selectively
integrate into all the plastidancy but
basically the efficiency of
electropriation is greatly influenced by
the cell size or the perforation status
of or the activation status of the T
cells
so I believe the RF plus tease has made
possess certain characteristics that
make them more susceptible to an
extrapolation
so in in fact when we introduced uh DNA
plasmid containing gfb GFE without
transposing just a DNA plasmid all the
plus dbmc showed a better better
transfection efficiency than other minus
cortisol uh pbmc
so
probably the characteristics of the
barrel plus pbmc could be a key factor
and we have
obtained a consistent result in the
manufacturing of our our Rich car T
cells regardless of the electro
operation device
hey thank you
um are there any differences in genome
insertion profiles between the piggyback
engineered and virally engineered car T
cells
yeah we have checked uh Jinx Gene
insertion of the our piggyback artist
cells and the gene insertion profile of
retro Quality Sales were widely
published and we have no differences in
the gene insertion profile of piggyback
and retro car details and we don't see
any preferential integration specs to
the specific side of the genome in the
pig piggyback transports on cortisols
one other question uh maybe comment is
please tell us more about why you didn't
use hyperactive transposase
yes it's also very good questions as I
mentioned the
main drawbacks of the use of transposing
transposing for making cartesians is a
relatively low low efficiency of the car
T cells and the most of the researchers
uses hyperactive transposing instead of
original form of pig transposium to
increase the transfection efficiency but
in turn
theoretically this may affect the
chromosomal instability because of the
insertion mutagenesis may occur so we
stick with the use of hyper original
piggyback transplant instead of
hyperactive form
and
we modified the expansion protocol to
increase the transfection efficiency
not using the hyperactive form
but using the original form
combined with the modified expansions
it's just a safety concern
perfect and then a follow-up question to
that is why did you use piggyback
instead of told to or Sleeping Beauty
excuse me
why did you use piggyback instead of uh
pull two or Sleeping Beauty
oh
I
I don't have any specific reasons we
just
familiar with the piggyback transposal
and I believe the piggyback
vaping Beauty and told to have a
original characteristics for making
protein cells but and I don't see any
differences or any solid conical benefit
or differences in a piggyback and
Sleeping Beauty criticials but will you
still stick with piggyback
perfect thank you
um one uh participant has a practical
question they wanted to understand how
much does it cost to make one product
from one patient
uh it depends on the
the cost of the
reagent or and the manufacturing
durations but in our product
I need to calculate in Japanese Yen to
Dollars but
um
it takes a long time to calculate the
Japanese yen to does but it's far less
than the cost of the retroviral
cortisone
Maybe
we can go on to the next question
um how is the transfection efficiency
without activation compared to with
activation
uh it's a very also very good question
we try to
introduce some car T cells using the
activated T cells and but these T cells
were
it were introduced in contrast Gene
after the electropriation but soon after
they got exhausted and showed an
activation in the cell death so finally
we got no live cells during this
expansion so that's why we switched to
use
um non-active T cells because probably
uh the activation May
some benefit may have some benefit but
also activation May induce the cell
damages after the electroperative T
cells
another question is during day 14
culture do you activate the car T cells
or how do you maintain them
yeah actually I stimulate core T cells
once only as I've shown in the slide on
day three I'm sorry on day one by
um the ancient ex presenting
anti-important fetal cell then let them
grow for 45. that's enough for our
cortisol manufacturing process
term functionality of car T cells
uh this is also a very good question as
some of the audience May notice their
safety issues of piggyback transposal
car T cells are reported in Australian
group
and the researchers found two Cartesian
derived lymphoma patient in their
clinical trial and they're but still
there are no reasons why
derived in the specific clinical trial
because they use hyperactive transposes
for manufacturing T cells but another
group also
um also uses hyperactive transportation
for their clinical Trend trials and
their no safety concerns in the
so the probably
we need to
definitely we need to improve the
manufacturing process more safety or the
the cartesia has got more safety profile
but again we need to establish a
reliable uh
reliable process in a clinical trial to
see the long-term functionality and in
our ongoing or upcoming clinical trial
we screen the patient ready by our
radiological Imaging including the Pet
Scan to
eliminate the chance of the secondary
malignancies
that is
probably needed in a early stage
clinical trial
well you just answered one of my other
questions about the long-term safety
concerns and so we won't go to that
question and then I guess I think you
already asked something similar to this
but I want to make sure I get to the
point so why
um why
cd45ra had a higher transduction ratio
than the CD 45ra negative cells and did
you find a similar outcome using
different car molecules
yeah actually I don't have
the data uh basic data why cdr45 all
they have uh susceptible to
the elector operation
but and also we are now trying to see
find out
if there is another cell fraction that
is susceptible to cd40 like cd45 other
positive cells but as I mentioned
earlier probably the electroporation
efficiency
um depends on this on the activation
status or the cell type of
and
um the perforation status so maybe
there should be some
some critical characteristics that is
susceptible to to the electropriation
and
we are still investigating
to to find this kind of that piece of
fraction
great
um another one came in do you have your
own patents around your
transposon-based manufacturing platform
Yes actually yes
um there are I guess there are no patent
on the original form of uh piggyback
transposal but as I mentioned
um it is quite important
for that
for the pig piggyback transpose
manufacturing to establish optimized
expansion protocol so we have some
patent for our manufacturing process of
of carti cells
uh I don't see any other questions
coming in
so we'll give it a couple more seconds
and see if there's any more questions
feel free to type them into the Q a box
and
I guess
yeah I didn't answer the number four did
you notice any differences between
Electro operation system
you can certainly answer that one I
didn't know if you wanted to answer that
one or not but I you can certainly
answer that one uh yeah uh yeah I I
talked in the in the slide so we have
compared the several electric operation
system the each Electro protection
system have our own characteristics but
we can definitely see some differences
in terms of the Electoral operation in
terms of the transaction efficiency or
the
or the persistency after the lecture
operation
and the currently we chose Max site it's
uh best uh characteristics in the
combination with our expansion protocol
protocol
perfect and then it looks like we have
another one that did come in how much
can the cost be reduced by using trans
programs
okay so probably the cost of GMP
compliant biology inductor should be
very very much expensive but and this uh
uh induces the cost of the
car teaser product and our we are using
a GMP compliant just a DNA vectors
and the gym even GMP compliant the
making a DNA plasmid is much much
cheaper than the viral Gene viral uh
vectors Manufacturing
so
so this is the cost reduction
point of our piggyback transposome
courtesy
perfect
all right I don't see any other
questions that have come in so I will at
this point say thank you shigeki and ask
you if you have any final comments oh I
just thought actually two more just came
in yes
um
so any impact of different
electroporation systems on expanded cell
phenotypes
ah this is also a very good question so
we have we should optimize
the electorporation conditions
or
the cell types or
even
even the
electric operation machines as the cell
types and the use of the
the
buffer or the volume or concentration of
the cells so
I found
some optimal conditions for resting T
cells by combination with the max High
system and our our expansion step but if
we try to find another uh protocol for
another sales or another system we have
to optimize for age conditions
okay and next question did you see any
differences in the phenotypes of the car
T cells when using MEK Inhibitors versus
dasatinum
ah actually I didn't tried using the
satinib instead
we just use Mac Inhibitors but
so I can't explain the differences in
the phenotype of car T cells but
in we have a very uh much more
um the memory like T cells when we use a
Mac inhibitor for manufacturing
cortisols and in the previous paper I
talked in the top
the researchers also showed a memory lag
phenotype when the cultural cartesians
with the satinive
Perfect all right I think that does kind
of wrap us up so I will ask you if you
had any final comments that you wanted
to give to our audience before we could
wrap up the session
oh thank you very much so I am actually
a pediatric oncologist and still work in
the clinic so I hope these kind of
techniques or new newly developed drugs
will be introduced into the clinic
thank you and we do as well um and thank
you again shigeki for your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank lab rates for
supporting today's educational webcast
and before we go I would like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for the interesting questions that came
in via the the Q a box
um for those that didn't have a chance
to submit and for watching we'll have an
on-demand period that will be addressed
by the speaker and we'll contact you
um via the email you signed up for at
the time of registration to let you know
when that on-demand session will be
available
um we will be available for replay and
we encourage you to share your email
with the colleagues who have missed
today's Live Events and visit maxsite to
learn more about our technology until
next time goodbye